[Music]
[Applause]
hello everyone this video will be a bit
different than all my previous videos as
this is the chest time machine here in
this game we have an epic moment in
chess history Geary offered the draw
team to f6 rook to d1 King back to his
six giri giri basically offers a
threefold repetition west i opened with
the d4 and now we what sorry about that
sorry about that sorry about that
ask her about that sorry about that he's
gonna you know just fix that and he's
not sorry about it either that almost
never happens
no that never happens I've never seen
that now let's enjoy this game or don't
we have rook to g6 preparing ideas like
like a small rook lifts coming to g7 so
Carlsen sacrificed another pawn okay he
blundered the first one but he
sacrificed the second one and now Queen
t1 check not Queen to e vine choke Queen
to e1 check notice that there is no good
way to prevent the pond from queening
but there is one good way if the if the
knight moves for example Knight to g7 or
whatever then look Luke is ready to use
the sword Knight to f6 check will of
course win the game to always just get
this over with all right
that's very nice so feel free to pause
the video here but not for too long and
figure out why this he play Knight to e5
allowing Knight captures Queen on d4 I'm
just kidding don't do it as nice the c5
was actually a terrible blunder sure now
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I did some since I do have a better
graphics card now I try to improve the
quality of my camera so I don't know if
it's any any better but if it is you
know do do comments so so I would know
now what kind of a hat is it I have no
idea could be some traditional wear but
whichever the case it does look like it
gives +15 to agility he's a top level
Smash Bros player so there we have it
let's see now let's see if Michael can
smash this bro he was the highest rated
player in the world with a rating over
29,000
9,000 that could be right
2,900 here you can end the game
immediately basically but this was 1874
and in those days it wasn't just about
you know beating your opponent you also
had to be cool while while you did it
what Magnus also had um oh that's that's
not what I wanted to show him the c6
pawn is under attack and there is no
there is no good reply here you cannot
defend it your Bishop is just away in
there on g7 it's you know it's supposed
to be a dragon and here it's not even a
lizard and this is the well moment where
the magic happens capture capture
capture captures captures captures the
characteristic captures Jefferson
captures captures captures captures
hunters captures captures captures
captures captures captures counters
counters counters counters counters
coverage captures captures captures the
toughest toughest captures captures
captures capture capture
[Music]
while you wander on that I will have a
nice sip of my water now yes I know your
your friends at the bar in the library
are incredibly impressed but they should
be also here we have a nice man on a
horse because I mean why not I'm now
going to announce the result of the
second match between Hikaru Magnus so
close your ears if you don't want to
hear it you should decide it to go
Bishop to e7 to allow me this beautiful
structure so I can use this as a
thumbnail it's like they're playing
these crazy games just just so I would
show them on the channel so feel free to
pause the video here if you you know
enjoy you know posing videos so there I
gave you some time to consider will you
pause for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations as it's really not
not an easy move to find and for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations no I totally messed it
up if any of you saw came to h1 it's
than just you know hats off to you you
are a true true you know gentlemen of
the game I did have some ideas of what
the play if he captures the rook but
mostly my plan was to resign the game
III I'd expect a bigger trophy for the
winner of the grand chester finals you
you know you fight for an entire year to
be here and now you win it and it looks
like well it looks like a vazh but then
again okay you do have a 150,000 dollars
a cash prize for winning first place so
I guess it's not all about the trophy
and you can see that his starting number
is 69 no I which is just insane Carlson
did play rook captures on b7 with check
and in this position nested in their
gift totally ignored this check and he
played Knight - III and he checked
Magnus Carlsen while he himself was in
check if the knight was here instead of
here then it'd be good because then
you'd have like look to c1 checkmate
since the knight from here will be
covering the f2 square
but you don't so that's that's too bad
for Magnus and Hikaru and Nakamura drew
their games so the match was a draw it
would be you know pretty much a crime
against chess to go for a draw here I
don't think anyone is crazy enough to
challenge the engines and not yet at
least we have to wait for that chosen
one to you know help us fight the
machines you can't out tall tall I'm
pretty sure everyone enjoys chess he who
says he doesn't either doesn't know the
rules or his line for some reason so
this is this is one of the weirder
points in in any line that you'll see it
was in this position that eleven Arnon
and shot him I'm not resigned but drew
their game and this comes with a threat
of Queen to g6 checkmate and also Queen
to h7 checkmate and how do you stop this
well you don't I did try to find a photo
of the two of them playing in this
tournament I wasn't successful but after
searching some dark corners of the
Internet I was able to find an even
better photo so here it is it's not a
very high quality photo but still it's
you know you definitely want to have
this photo I will put a link in the
description below so you can you know
use it for whatever you want me you want
to print it and put it you know on your
fridge or something this will result in
at least a small nervous breakdown but
you know so yeah that's it for this
video I do hope you enjoyed it and as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here and that's it thank you for
watching and I'll see you soon oh and
meadow says hi
[Music]